If you're like me,
when you hear the words
"Alaskan divorce court"
you probably have some
picture in your head of, like,
a 70-year-old bounty hunter
arm-wrestling
a one-legged prostitute
over who gets the fishing rights
up at Dead Guy Lake.
It's always the bear, by
the way. It's always the bear.
But last week,
in a progressive move,
Alaskan courts became the first
in the nation to reclassify pets
in divorce proceedings
to allow for joint custody.
It's a very revolutionary...
Are you guys thinking
about getting divorced?
-Is this why you're very
excited? "Oh, you can do that."
It's a very revolutionary move
in divorce proceedings
because everywhere else, dogs
are treated basically the same
as a car,
which was causing problems
in some parts of Alaska
where their dog
-is technically their car.
-(laughter)
Uh... so...
-(applause)
-This made me realize...
Made me realize I don't think
most of us have any idea
what goes on
in an Alaskan divorce court.
So comedians, what is another
rule you'd hear
in an Alaskan divorce court?
-Jenny. -That you are entitled
to a no-fault divorce
if your spouse (bleep) a Yeti
or Sarah Palin.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(laughter)
-Points.
-Oh, yeah.
-HARDWICK: Andrew.
-Oh.
Two-drink minimum,
don't touch the dancers.
-Next up-- Areola Borealis!
-(laughter, applause)
HARDWICK: Points.
Oh, what a great stripper name!
(applause)
-Oh, that's the best stripper
name ever. -Thank you, dude.
-Erik.
-Okay, uh,
you can walk away scot-free
if you didn't get a good look
at them
because it's dark for six months
out of the year.
-HARDWICK: Yeah. Points.
-(laughter)